thank you very much
thank you
beautiful out here this time of year
in the past nine months my
administration has initiated the
single greatest mobilization in u.s
history pioneering developing and
manufacturing therapies and vaccines
in record time numbers like nobody's
seen before
no medical breakthrough of this scope
and magnitude has ever been
achieved this rapidly this quickly and
we're very proud of it and had
tremendous help from the military
generals admirals and many of the great
people at the white house
operation warp speed is unequaled
and unrivaled anywhere in the world and
leaders of other countries have called
me to congratulate
us on what we've been able to do and
we've helped
many countries with their ventilators
and all of the problems they were having
and i'd like to
congratulate everyone involved in this
effort it's been an incredible effort
as a result of operation warp speed
pfizer announced on monday that its
china virus vaccine is more than 90
percent effective
this far exceeds any and all
expectations nobody thought they'd get
to that level
and we have others coming which we think
will be at equal level maybe
more of that's possible in july my
administration reached an agreement with
pfizer to provide
1.95 billion dollars to support the mass
manufacturing and distribution of 100
million doses
with the option to purchase a total of
600 million doses shortly thereafter
our investment will make it possible for
the vaccine to be provided by pfizer
free of charge pfizer said it wasn't
part of warp speed but that turned out
to be a
unfortunate misrepresentation they are
part that's why we gave them the 1.95
million
billion dollars and uh
it was an unfortunate mistake that they
made when they said that
we will work to secure an emergency use
authorization
which should be coming down extremely
soon and my administration will then
coordinate
the distribution of the vaccine and
it will be approved i think again it
will be approved very very
quickly we hope the average development
timeline
for the vaccine including clinical tests
and manufacturing can take eight to 12
years
through operation warp speed we're doing
it in less than one year
if you had a different administration
with different people
what we've done would have taken in my
opinion three four
five years and it would have been in the
fda forever
this is five times faster than the
fastest prior vaccine development in
history
five times faster say it again five
times faster
nobody can believe it actually three
other vaccines are also in the final
stages of trial
they'll arrive within a few weeks and
they will also be
mass produced and the delivery will be
very rapid we're
ready to go the vaccine will be
distributed to front-line workers the
elderly and high-risk americans
immediately
it will be very a matter of weeks get
out
very very much ahead of schedule any
schedule that
i said we're going to be far ahead of
that
we know that this virus primarily
targets older populations and those
with underlying health conditions well
over 99.98 percent of those
under the age of 50 make a full and
quick recovery
by giving the vaccine to high-risk
individuals right away will dramatically
reduce
hospitalizations and deaths
case levels are high but a lot of the
case levels are high because of the fact
that
we have the best testing program
anywhere in the world we've developed
the most and the best tests and we test
far more than any other country so it
shows obviously
more cases by vaccinating the elderly
and the high risk we will
effectively end this phase of the
pandemic and allow seniors to reclaim
their golden years the golden years of
their lives which is so incredible
and it's about time that they can have
those golden years again this process is
starting
right away millions of doses will soon
be going out the door they're all ready
waiting for that final approval as soon
as april the vaccine will be available
to the entire general population
with the exception of places like new
york state where
for political reasons the governor
decided to say and you know
i don't think it's good politically i
think it's very bad from a health
standpoint but
he wants to take his time on the vaccine
he doesn't trust where the vaccine's
coming from these are coming from the
greatest
uh companies anywhere in the world
greatest labs in the world
but he doesn't trust the fact that it's
this white house this administration
so we won't be delivering it to new york
until we have authorization to do so and
that pains me to say that this is a very
successful
amazing vaccine at 90 percent and more
but
uh so the governor governor cuomo will
have to let us know when he's ready for
it otherwise
we we can't we can't be delivering it to
a state
that won't be giving it to its people
immediately and i know many i know the
people of new york very well i know they
want it
so the governor will let us know when
he's ready he's had some very bad
editorials recently about
this this statement and what's happened
with respect to nursing homes and his
handling of
nursing homes and i hope he doesn't
handle this as badly as he's handled the
nursing homes
but we're ready to provide it as soon as
they let us know that they'll
actually use it and again it's a very
safe and
a great vaccine already we have among
the lowest case fatality rates
our country anywhere in the world the
entire world
and we've performed significantly better
than our peer countries
as far as therapeutics are concerned my
administration's also made critical
investments and therapies that have
helped reduce the mortality rate by 85
percent that's
to me one of the most exciting things
it's incredible some of the antibody
vaccines and others that
have come out and have really helped
people 85 percent
last month the fda approved remedy
severe
and we've secured enough room to severe
to treat 850
000 patients my administration finalized
an agreement with eli lilly
to purchase the first doses of their
antibody
therapy which shows amazing results
this treatment will be available
completely free of course to patients 5
000 units have already been shipped
and many more going out the door as we
speak were also reached an agreement
with
astrazeneca for the large-scale
manufacturing of their antibody
treatment
which is excellent we expect to issue
emergency use authorizations for a
number of additional treatments
in the near future tremendous promise
but remember the 85 percent number
that's an incredible
incredible number but we have some
tremendously promising
drugs online and ready to come out
we have ensured that our frontline
workers have all the tools they need
my administration's invoked the defense
production act and related authorities
over 100 times
and have made a historic investment into
our industrial base
all states that requested ppe from the
federal government have received the ppe
almost immediately upon request every
american who needed a ventilator has had
access to a ventilator think of that
very complicated piece of equipment very
expensive
and we haven't had one person in this
whole country that
has requested or needed a ventilator
that hasn't had it
every single request has been
immediately filled so that was something
that was a great job and now we're
helping the rest of the world with
ventilators because it's a very hard
thing
we're producing them thousands of
thousands of ventilators a month
the federal government has 22 thousand
beds immediately available for states
and jurisdictions that need additional
capacity
but we think that it's going to start
going down possibly
very quickly we'll see what happens but
with the vaccine it'll you'll see
numbers going down within a matter of
months and it'll go down very rapidly as
we continue to combat the virus our
economy
is rebounding far beyond any
expectations i see the stock market's up
almost 400 points today again and
it's ready to break the all-time record
our jobs records are
incredible the job numbers are
incredible in the last six months we've
created over 13 million jobs and slashed
the unemployment rate
by more than half last quarter we
witnessed the fastest economic growth
ever recorded in the history of our
country 33.1 percent it's a number that
is more than double our highest that was
in 1952
and we've more than doubled at the
united states experienced the smallest
economic contraction
and the most rapid economic recovery of
any major western nation
we went down less and we went up more
which is quite a combination of facts
while healthy americans have gone back
to work into school we continue to
spare no expense to protect the elderly
and the vulnerable
according to some estimates a national
lockdown costs 50 billion dollars a day
and hundreds of thousands of jobs every
single day
ideally we won't go to a lockdown i will
not go this
administration will not be going to a
lockdown hopefully the
the uh whatever happens in the future
who knows which administration will be i
guess time will tell but
uh i can tell you this administration
will not go to a lockdown
there won't be necessity lockdowns cost
lives and they cost a lot of problems
the cure
cannot be you got to remember cannot be
worse than the problem itself and i've
said it many times
and when you look at what happens during
a lockdown i just
say it very loudly it's horrible what
happens with drugs
alcohol depression loss of jobs
business closures it's a terrible thing
so this administration will not go under
any circumstances will not go to a
lockdown but we'll be very vigilant very
careful
we understand the disease it's a it's a
complicated disease but we understand it
very well
we ask all americans to remain vigilant
especially
as the weather gets colder and it
becomes more difficult to go outside and
to have
outside gatherings and with that i just
want to
ask some very talented people to come up
and say a few words
uh general purna and dr
slowy have been incredible uh
the general is really getting started
right now but he's really what we don't
know and what people don't know he
started putting this all together six
months ago and you're going to see some
real action so general maybe you'll
start it off
and then doctor you'll go right after
that thank you very much and then we're
going to
finish it off with mike pence okay thank
you please
thank you sure
thank you mr president hi everybody
so operation warp speeds mission is to
enable and accelerate the development of
vaccines and therapeutic to help control
the coven-19 pandemic
and save lives on may 15
almost six months ago to the day we
stated the goal of the operation which
was to have
vaccines and therapeutics available and
approved for use in the u.s population
by the end of the year 2020. we said
then that
while very challenging the goal was
credible and therefore
was worth trying with the best
our best to achieve it today we're
almost six months later
and i think we can say that significant
progress
has been made and while we are not there
yet we are
close to the objective
let me share with you some facts if i
look at the vaccine side
we've selected a portfolio of six
vaccines
using three different platform
technologies and we elected to have two
vaccines from each
platform technology first platform
is what's called messenger rna and two
vaccines using that platform
where in the portfolio one by pfizer
and one by uh moderna the second
platform is using
what's called live viral vectors and we
had one vaccine from j and j
and one vaccine from asteroids and
zenica in partnership with oxford
university and the third platform
was the recombinant protein platform
with one vaccines from a biotech company
here in the u.s called novavax
and another one from a partnership
between sanofi
and glaxosmithkline these vaccines are
now
six vaccines are all in the clinical
development stages
and four of them are in phase three
trials
and of the four that are in phase three
trials
two have effectively completed
enrollment in the phase three trial
and one of the two has announced on
monday to i think
uh thrilling information that they had
90
efficacy that was the pfizer vaccine
demonstrating that
vaccination is possible against kovite
19
that the kind of choices we have made in
terms of the antigen selected
was effective and
made us optimistic that other vaccine
may also be effective on wednesday the
same week
just this wednesday moderne the other
company with the vaccine using
similar platform technology messenger
rna announces they have
achieved the number of cases in their
trial to allow for
first interim analysis and i would
expect
that shortly probably next week we may
hear
what i hope to be another very good
information regarding
unification's vaccine the two other
vaccines
that are in phase 3 trial that are using
the live vector
platform the jnj vaccine and the
astrozenica vaccine
have recruited already a few thousand
subjects in their
trials i would like to take this
opportunity to invite as many americans
as possible who would like to volunteer
to participate in these clinical trials
as that's the only way we are able to
achieve
a demonstration of the safety and the
efficacy of these vaccines
the last two vaccines the protein
recombinant protein vaccines
are planned to start their phase 3
trials within the next
few weeks and while
we are developing this vaccine we
haven't only looked at the clinical
development
of course in partnership with the
companies that are the sponsors for the
vaccine we also
invested very significantly
in the manufacturing of this vaccine in
such a way as to when we have
the clinical efficacy demonstration
with these vaccines we would also have
vaccine doses
to be able to immunize the u.s
population
so the two vaccines that are completing
their phase 3 trial
are likely to be filing their
files with the fda
for potential emergency use
authorization within the next few weeks
and hopefully if approved they could be
used for immunization in the u.s
population in the month of december
and we have we plan to have enough
vaccine doses available for use in the
u.s population
to immunize about 20 million individuals
in the month of december
and another 25 to 30 million
per month on an ongoing basis from there
on
and as of the month of february or march
if we have more vaccines approved such
as the live
vectored vaccine we may be able to
immunize a larger number of americans
on an ongoing basis per month
operation warp speed didn't only focus
on vaccines
we also looked at therapeutics and we
have worked with a number of companies
developing monoclonal antibodies in
particular
that are able to neutralize the virus
as mr president said we have announced
partnerships with eli lilly with
regeneron and with astrazeneca
and on monday eli lili's monoclonal
antibody was
granted an emergency use authorization
to treat the patients that are infected
and at risk of hospitalization
the regeneron monoclonal antibodies
have been also filed for emergency use
authorization which is currently under
review
and is potentially
reaching approval within the next few
weeks and finally
astrazeneca just in the last few days
has received
a green light to start two large phase
three trials
with their monoclonal antibodies
supported by
operation warp speed to prevent
the acquisition of covid19 disease in
very frail
subjects or in very high risk subjects
as a protective alternative to a vaccine
so potentially two vaccines and two
therapeutics may be granted an emergency
use authorization before the end of this
year
i think it's a remarkable achievement
within a period of
six to seven months it is important to
note that this
progress has been achieved without any
political interference
i said it many times and at every step
has been and is being judged by
independent
expert bodies whether it's when the fda
grants the green light to go into
clinical trials
or whether when the data safety
monitoring boards
review the safety of the studies on an
ongoing basis and sometimes put them on
hold as
i'm sure you have witnessed with the
astrazeneca
vaccine for instance and
these same data safety monitoring boards
are
the independent boards of experts that
analyze the efficacy
of the vaccines and the safety of the
vaccines
and tell the companies whether they
should progress with the filing of an
emergency use authorization
or not so it's not the companies it's
not
operational warp speed it's not the us
government
it is independent experts that
assess the safety and the efficacy of
the vaccines
that are being tested and when the fda
will review these vaccines
and this therapeutics they will
also have the advice public advice
from boars one of them is called the
verpac that is the advisory board to the
fda for vaccine reviews
uh on after review of the of the
of the data transparently and available
to everybody to look into
before the fda then make its decision to
either authorize a vaccine
or not authorize it on that basis
i personally feel very comfortable to
say that the vaccines and the
therapeutics that we have helped
developed and accelerate
will be judged independently and if
approved should be used by all in the
population
because i believe vaccination is likely
to be the cornerstone
among all the other measures that we
have to take
to help us really control this pandemic
i will now pass to my co-leader general
perna who will tell you more about
the support that the operation has
provided to
manufacturing of the vaccine and also to
their distribution thank you very much
mr president thank you for allowing me
to continue service
of our great nation as a co-leader with
dr monsef salawi on this mission
let me start by emphasizing for me what
is operational warp speed about it is
about saving lives
and it is a herculean task uh that the
president put us on
many months ago uh and as dr salawi just
laid out
we are making steady progress uh and we
are ready to execute
through the whole of american approach
we have leveraged the best of nation
in federal government local states
industry and academia to expand the
capacity and capability
to achieve our mission it has
been powerful we have capitalized on the
best contracting
logistics and planning experts available
to synchronize and integrate all phases
of the
operation from development of the
vaccine
manufacturing of the vaccine and finally
distribution
of the vaccine six months ago the
capacity did not exist
in our nation's pharmaceutical
production base
we went to work building brick and
mortar manufacturing facilities
bringing in the right specialized
machinery and equipment
and prioritizing supply chain
materials through the defense production
act
today we expect to have tens of millions
of doses
immediately following eua and we will
distribute them
as soon as the fda
applies to eua we will do that
within 24 hours of the eua we are
harnessing the strength of commercial
industry
and existing vaccine delivery
capabilities
and infrastructure our nation deserves
this vaccines will be allocated pro-rata
by population
so that we ensure fair and equitable
across
we need the states who are part of the
planning
to accept the vaccine
we are working closely along with the
cdc the 64 jurisdictions and states
to ensure vaccine can safely and quickly
get to those
who need it first and then we have plans
to ensure that it spreads exponentially
across our country
and that no place is left without a
vaccine
at the end of the day our success is
going to be judged
by the availability of the vaccine as
shots go in arms it is
the partnerships we have formed with the
pharmaceutical companies like
pfizer and moderna distribution
companies like mckesson
fedex and ups and pharmacies like cvs
and walgreens that have agreed to do
things differently
to think how can we get this to the
american people
in the most rapid and expedition
expeditionist
way we will be successful because of
this all
of america approach this collaboration
this effort that everybody is leading
towards
i will end where i started this is about
saving lives
the lives of the great american people
and we will not rest
until we are successful and that we have
irreversible momentum to returning our
nation back to normal
thank you mr president thank you general
very much great job
alex please sir
thank you mr president for providing the
leadership that's gotten us
where we are today the success that
operation warp speed has realized so far
has been made possible only because of
the bold vision you announced
not even six months ago right here in
the rose garden
to highlight three of the remarkable
accomplishments we've seen just this
week
first pfizer announced very promising
data on its vaccine candidate
second eli the ii the fda authorized and
we have begun to distribute and
administer
eli lilly's monoclonal antibody to help
americans at risk for serious disease
stay out of the hospital third another
vaccine company mederina announced that
it's reached a critical
clinical trial milestone meaning we may
see data from them within days
back in the spring we were told by all
of the experts that a vaccine was a year
or a year and a half away and the
announcements i just highlighted would
have been unthinkable
the president said that's not acceptable
and thanks to the support he's provided
we're now
on track to deliver a safe and effective
vaccine to our most vulnerable this year
as i worked with the president to
assemble this team and organize this
effort
his support was indispensable at each
step of the way
we went out and found the very best
people on the planet to do the job who
you just talked with
dr slowing the world's most successful
vaccine developer
general purda one of the world's most
qualified logistics leaders
when i first talked to dr slowly and
general purna about our goals and
recruited them to this effort
we dreamed of being at the point we're
at today
on track to achieve the incredibly
ambitious goal we set together
the president gave us the full financial
support we needed
enabling us to invest more than 10
billion dollars to de-risk vaccine
companies development efforts
and manufacture product in advance
our completely unprecedented partnership
with the defense department has given us
a comprehensive public private plan for
distribution
and helped each operation warp speed
vaccine maker secure what they needed
for manufacturing
including pfizer's ongoing production
this week
operation warp speed has always had one
goal saving lives
the president has given ows the
independence it needs to achieve that
goal
and ensure that we're following the
procedures that americans expect for any
medical product they take at every step
ensuring patient safety
has been our top priority this process
has been driven solely by science and
data
so it's a shame that some one example
being the governor of new york
have actually injected politics into the
process and suggested the possibility of
intentionally delaying access
to an fda authorized vaccine which is
simply unconscionable
because the president has delivered the
full funding we need the best people on
the planet
and real independence for this project
operation warp speed is doing
something that's never been done before
in history this success means there is
light
at the end of the tunnel right now is
not the time to let our guard down
we continue to encourage americans to
follow the three w's
wash your hands watch your distance wear
a mask when you can't watch your
distance
and avoid settings where you can't do
those things because of the incredible
american spirit
because of what great scientists and
public servants and innovators have done
through operation warp speed
we have such a bright future ahead of us
if we continue to protect ourselves our
families and our communities then i
firmly believe that future will be here
very soon thank you mr president for
making that
very bright future possible for the
american people
thank you mike pence please
thank you mr president and on behalf of
the white house coronavirus task force
i was grateful to just have a few
minutes today to commend the team
of operation warp speed it was your
vision
that we could harness the ingenuity and
the creativity
of america's greatest pharmaceutical and
research companies
to speed in record time a vaccine that
would save
american lives you told the american
people that we would have a vaccine
before the end of the year and
some scoffed at that timetable but i can
tell you the team on operation warp
speed
didn't these great research companies
didn't
and as you've articulated here mr
president
the american people can be comforted
with all the news this week
that help is on the way that literally
pending fda approval
of the pfizer vaccine and perhaps very
soon
another vaccine that will be submitted
by moderna and
even other companies that before the
year is out we'll be able to administer
a vaccine to tens of millions of
americans as you've said mr president
beginning with those most vulnerable
beginning with our
seniors all across this country
beginning with our health care workers
and
first responders at the point of the
need it is an
unprecedented medical mobilization the
greatest
in the history of our country and i join
you in commending
this team let me also say mr president
that
the white house coronavirus task force
will be meeting
with our nation's governors in our
regular conference call this monday
we'll be reviewing with them the
progress on the development of a vaccine
our plans for distribution
but we'll also be reviewing each and
every state's
specific plans for distributing the
vaccine continue to urge governors who
have those plans developed and prepared
and ready for immediate implementation
and finally mr president as we see cases
rising around the country as we see
hospitalizations rising around the
country
i want to encourage the american people
with the news
that as we have done from the very
beginning we're going to continue to
move heaven and earth
to make sure that your family has access
to the level of health care
that we'd want any one of our members of
our family to have
i spoke to fema today and as we heard
reported at our last
task force meeting as president we're
receiving requests
from states for ppe for personnel but
we're meeting all of those requests
and according to our team on the ground
we continue to believe that we'll be
able to meet the request for ppe
and equipment both from the strategic
national stockpile
also from the commercial market to make
sure that those needs
are all met the american people can also
be confident because of the system that
you established that
since this past july we're actually able
to track
ppe gowns and gloves and n95 masks on a
hospital
by hospital basis so we can continue to
deliver as you said mr president
on that extraordinary record in america
where no american who's ever required
a ventilator has ever been denied a
ventilator no american who's ever
acquired an icu bed has ever been denied
an icu bed
so the good news today through operation
warp speed mr president his help is on
the way
it's on the way right around the corner
as one of the members of our task force
said recently the
cavalry is coming but we want to
encourage every american that we're
going to continue to make sure
that our health care system has the
resources to support
the equipment and supplies that they
need and we also
mr president as as we see cases rising
particularly in
in the heartland in this country but in
communities all across america we
encourage every
american as the secretary didn't as you
have continue to
practice good hygiene wash your hands
practice social distancing wear a mask
when that's not possible we all have a
role to play we all know what to do
to protect the vulnerable to look after
our families and our neighbors and
friends and we encourage
every american with all the good news
this week
to continue to be persistent in putting
the health of yourself
your family your neighbors co-workers
and friends first and and we'll get
through this
and we'll get through this together
thank you mr president thank you very
much mike
and thank you everybody thank you very
much
[Applause]
is